STEVE GROVE: Are we good?
All right.
We're going to start off
with a video here.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Everyone good to go?
-Good.
-Good to go.
-I'm good.
-I'm gonna click on
Start Broadcast.
Hi, everybody.
Once again, we're going to have
our virtual star party
working the telescopes today.
I love science.
I love communicating
and exploring
about space and astronomy.
So when Google+ came out, I
thought, wouldn't it be cool
if we could get a telescope
streaming an image right into
the Hangout?
-We've got Mike Phillips, and
he's in North Carolina.
We've got Gary Gonnella.
What's your view, Gary?
-The Monkey Heads in the
upper part of Orion.
-Before, this was impossible.
But now we're getting people
from Mexico, and South
America, and South
Africa, Malaysia.
We're starting to capture
the whole Earth.
Because suddenly, there is a way
we are able to bring all
these people together
and put on a show.
-Oops.
Too.
Close.
-I think everyone's
ready but Mike.
Oh, I think I see something.
Can you move it a little
down, Mike?
There it is.
Oh, man, look at that.
Being able to look out into
space gives us context for how
we live in our day to
day experience.
It shows us that we're part
of this bigger universe.
Gary, you've got the
Rosette for me?
-I do.
-I mean, for us.
I mean for us.
For everyone to see.
Not just me.
-Don't kid us.
It's for you, Chris.
-It's for me, yeah.
-Now we have Saturn is green.
You guys are just into
the [INAUDIBLE].
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
STEVE GROVE: Well,
hello, everyone.
And welcome to our Hangouts
Fireside Chat for all of you
here in the room and for
those of you online.
This session is really
about you.
We're here essentially to answer
your questions, hear
your ideas, and hear your
thoughts about Google+
Hangouts, arguably one of the
most exciting features on the
Google+ platform.
So really excited to make this
an interactive discussion with
all of you.
To get us started I want to
introduce our panel today.
On the far side over there
is Nikhyl Singhal.
Nikhyl is director of product
for real-time
communications at Google.
So that's not only Hangouts,
but also Google Voice and
Google Chat.
Nikhyl, before Google, founded
and sold two companies, the
most recent of which
was SayNow.
SayNow, for those of you who
haven't heard of it, was a
real-time social video
conferencing tool that allowed
celebrities and fans to connect
using telephone
conferencing and voicemail.
If you haven't heard of it,
it's likely that your
daughters or sisters have heard
of it because one in
three teenage girls in the
country was using SayNow when
Google acquired Nikhyl's
company in 2011.
So that's Nikhyl Singhal
on the far side.
And then next to Nikhyl
is Chee Chew.
Chee is our engineering
director for real-time
communications at Google.
He is based in Kirkland.
Before he saw the light and came
to Google, he worked for
14 years at Microsoft, working
on a variety of things.
Most recently, he worked on Xbox
LIVE, particularly on the
Windows Live part of it.
As you explained it to me,
porting the Xbox LIVE
experience onto other devices.
So this is how it's going
to work for our
conversation today.
I'm going to start the
conversation with Nikhyl and
Chee up here for a little bit,
set the groundwork for what
Hangouts are, where
they came from.
We'll do that for about
10 or 15 minutes.
And then the bulk of the time
really, for the 45 minutes we
have left, we want to
hear your questions.
You can either ask
them at the mics.
There's one there,
or one there if
you're here in the room.
Or if you're online and you
want to ask them on our
Moderator series, use
that link that we
have up on the screen.
If you're in the room, and
you're also shy, and you want
to do it via Moderator,
please feel free.
We'll get through as many
of them as we can.
The link is right there.
Just to get a sense for who's in
the crowd before we start,
so we have a sense of who you
all are, how many folks in the
room are developers?
Let's see a show of hands.
And then how many folks
in the room are media?
There's some media folks here?
Good, yeah.
We wanted to put a special call
out to media because we
think the applications
for Hangouts with
media are pretty exciting.
And then who here was at the
session right before this on
Hangout applications?
Good, so there's a strong group
of folks here who've
already been thinking about
Hangout applications and some
of the uses for them
as developers.
That's really useful.
So I'm going to start us out
with one more video to give us
a sense for the ways in which
Hangouts have been used.
And then we'll start
our conversation.
I should probably introduce
myself actually, which I
realize I haven't done.
My name is Steve Grove, and I
run our community partnerships
team on Google+.
Our mission is to partner with
influential individuals,
organizations, media companies,
et cetera to grow
the Google+ community.
So we've been using Hangouts a
lot with a lot of different
partners since we launched
last fall.
So here's a look at some of the
uses of Hangouts that we
saw early on in the days when
we launched the platform.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Hi.
-Look, grandpa's here.
-Hey, Javin, Chase,
how you doing?
-Hi, man.
-Oh my gosh.
-Are you kidding?
-Oh my god, shut up.
-Do it, do it.
-Are you wearing an apron?
-Whoa.
-You're wearing your sweaters.
-Oh.
-Ugh.
-Her right knee toward the
center of your foot.
-Moustache.
-Show the ring.
Show the ring.
-It is huge.
-It's gorgeous.
-Touchdown!
-[INAUDIBLE].
-We're having a wedding.
-I know.
-This is gonna be so cool.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
STEVE GROVE: Well, Chee,
let's start with you.
Give us a bit of the background
to Hangouts.
Why did Google start Hangouts
as a product?
And then why did Google think
about putting that product
within Google+?
CHEE CHEW: Sure.
So actually, at the very
beginning, the team wasn't
part of Google+.
We were actually the last major
team to join Google+.
Initially, the team was working
on one to one video
chat in Gmail.
And we were working on the
next version of that.
And the team was in Kirkland
and Sweden.
And one of the things that we
had done was we had set up a
permanent video link between
the two offices.
And so we had that ongoing.
So we were working on technology
in this area.
Something happened one
day when I came home.
And my wife was on
the computer.
She was working.
And she had a video window
going, but she wasn't really
talking to anyone.
It was just there.
And she was doing her work.
I was like, who are you
on a video chat with?
And she said, it's Arden--
who's my son.
And I was like, where's Arden?
And she said, well,
he's upstairs.
So there was a video link
between upstairs and
downstairs in my house.
I was like, why in the world
are you doing that?
And he answer was, well, he's
supposed to be studying, so I
banned him from downstairs
where he gets distracted.
He's supposed to be up in his
room, but he's lonely.
And so they just had a video
link between the two of each
other just to keep each
other company.
And that made me think about,
when I was in college, I
couldn't study when I was
sitting alone in my room.
I always went down to the common
room, and I hung around
with other people.
And we didn't really talk.
We just studied together.
And I was happier and more
productive when I was just
around people.
And I noticed that in our
engineering teams also.
We would be in video
calls together, and
we would debug together.
And sometimes there would be
long periods of silence.
But it just worked better when
people were accessible, and
they could ask something at
a spur of the moment.
So that was the spark of the
idea of video for something
more than just having a meeting,
but really just to
hang around with each other,
to keep each other company.
STEVE GROVE: So it wasn't
directed conversation.
This was actually having an
ambient conversation.
CHEE CHEW: Yeah, this ambient
conversation.
So that was, I guess, just
the spark of the idea.
It wasn't really well-formed
by that time.
But about that time, so this is
the end of 2010, about six
months before we released
Google+ I
was in Mountain View.
And Sergey, and Vic, and Bez
called me into a meeting and
pulled me in to talk to me, to
convince me to help Google+ by
adding text chat support
to Google+.
Since we weren't part of
Google+, they were asking to
lend a hand.
And so of course, I said, yeah,
we'll do that, but I had
this idea I wanted
to run by you.
So I explained this idea of an
ambient video sort of thing,
where most people can
come in and go out.
And they started to get it.
And so I then opened up my
laptop, and I joined into that
permanent video link.
So I was in California.
I joined into this permanent
link between
Kirkland and Stockholm.
And then all of a sudden, there
were engineers in those
two sites having this
conversation with Sergey, and
Vic, and Bez.
And it was cool.
I
People were really excited
about that.
And so that little spark turned
into a small flame.
And Sergey said, wow, this is a
neat idea, but we're trying
to ship in six months.
And you just have this
nugget of idea.
It's going to take us a long
time to even prototype it.
And the team had been
working on it.
So I said, no, it's like
five lines of code.
So Sergey says, well, then go,
and let's do it right now.
I had a flight to catch
in two hours.
So I said, uh, I have to go.
And Sergey said, well, you said
it's like five lines of
code, so just go do it.
So he was calling my bluff.
So they pulled me over to a
Google+ engineer, and they had
me explain how to do this.
They never let me
touch the code.
Because I'm the management
overhead, and you don't let me
near the actual code anymore.
So I explained how to do it.
It was really fast.
And then I said, I really
have to go.
I've got to catch a flight,
but when I land, I'll call
back, and see how you're
doing, and
then help from there.
So I took off, and the engineer
hadn't even compiled
the code yet.
He kept on working on
it, and I left.
I landed in Seattle.
I called him from the airport
just to find the engineer and
say, how's it going, do
you need any help?
And in that span of
three hours, that
engineer had finished.
He had built a new release, and
he had pushed that server
out to the company.
And as soon as I logged
in, Vic hit me
with a Hangout invite.
I joined there.
And there was Vic with a dozen
people, this big glass of
wine, and he goes, Chee,
we're in a Hangout.
And Sergey was there,
and then the Google+
leadership was there.
And I didn't know them all, so
he introduced me to them.
And I was like, wow, that's
kind of cool.
So I invited in the people from
Sydney in my team, and
from Stockholm, and Kirkland.
So I invited them in.
And we had this ambient
conversation, where people
brought other people in.
And that conversation lasted--
I landed at 9 o'clock.
It lasted at least
until 3:00 AM.
STEVE GROVE: So the first ever
Hangout lasted five hours.
CHEE CHEW: The first
ever Hangout lasted
more than six hours.
STEVE GROVE: Now you could have
launched this in Gmail or
in other places at Google.
What about launching Hangouts
within Google+
makes it really unique?
CHEE CHEW: Well, I think
part of the magic is
this ambient one.
You can do the directed
conversation, and I think this
is really important.
But also, part of the extra
magic that we have, I think,
is this ability for people to
connect with others and to
have friends of friends
bring in others.
And the social graph can
grow and spread.
I've met a lot of
amazing people.
And just before the session, I
saw a lot of people I've met
from around the world
through Hangouts.
And I think that connection
has been really, really
powerful, and I think
it's been a
unique part of Hangouts.
STEVE GROVE: As a social
experience?
CHEE CHEW: Yeah, absolutely.
STEVE GROVE: Nikhyl, I'd like to
hear from you a little bit
about what we've seen in terms
of how Hangouts have been used
by various groups
since launch.
To get into that topic, let's
play a little clip of one
group that has used Hangouts a
lot, right from the beginning.
And that's the media.
Let's watch a few clips from
media organizations.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Welcome to the AC360
Google+ page.
Add us to your circle, so you
can get the latest updates and
behind the scenes look
at the show.
-We're going to be conducting
Google Hangouts from time to
time to connect people in every
corner of the country to
talk about topics related
to Campaign 2012.
Sarah, you're the reporter
in this crowd.
What is going on with religion
these days in
the age of the internet?
-You were talking about
how religion is
surviving in this new age.
And I'd say, it's actually
thriving.
-I'm Maria Bartiromo at the
New York Stock Exchange.
Big shout-out to all my
friends on Google+.
-You think back, Saturday,
semi-finals.
What just pops in your mind?
-Uneven play.
-The Kentucky-Louisville game
especially was just-- it was
sloppy all the way around.
-I thought the first game was
totally entertaining.
You guys are all nuts.
-NBC Bay Area's George Kiriyama
is live at SFO, and
he's live via Google+
with us right now.
Because it's too dangerous to
use our live truck with a mast
going up there.
So he's talking to us live
over the internet.
George, what can you tell us?
-We have 61 flights canceled.
-We want to say thanks to
everyone who was on our cyber
count today.
We hope that you enjoy
your weekend.
-Good evening, I'm
Angie Bailey.
-And I'm Sarah Hill.
Thanks for joining us.
KOMU 8's Kristen James working
that story of Bryan Rankin.
-I'm Jake Tapper.
I'm the senior White House
correspondent for ABC News.
Welcome to this week's inaugural
Google+ Hangout for
a discussion of election
year politics.
So Emily, I think you
have the next one.
And your question is about
the US Supreme Court.
-If the Supreme Court rules
that all or a portion of
Obamacare is unconstitutional,
are there any positives that
President Obama could get
out of that decision?
-I think whatever happens, it's
probably not going to be
determined with this election.
I think though there's a
benefit, I think, to President
Obama if that happens.
-Anybody that has Google+
can use it.
It's sort of the concept of a
watch party at home, where
you'd be watching a speech on
your couch except you use it
from your laptops.
-It was definitely the magic of
technology made it happen.
-If you can bring people in to
be able to talk about the
issues that are driving
the day--
-I think this is gonna
be terrific.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
STEVE GROVE: So Nikhyl, you
launch a product like this,
you have a sense for how you
think it's going to be used.
And then it's out in the wild,
and people start using it.
What can you tell us about how
Hangouts have been used since
launch that has been instructive
for you about the
technology?
NIKHYL SINGHAL: So we launched
it almost exactly a year ago.
And what attracted me to
Hangouts initially was we
didn't want to just do
video conferencing.
I think there's a lot
of solutions out
there for video calling.
Google is very focused
on innovating here.
And I think when you look at
social communities and
real-time communication,
we're in the
first and second inning.
There's lots and lots of
interesting use cases.
We saw Chatroulette get born
about three, four years ago.
Clearly interesting.
That's one way to describe it.
There's been lots and lots
of other experiments.
But no one's really
figured it out.
And so I think Chee had
this instinct, the
team had this instinct.
We launched it.
And within the first few months,
the stories just
started to come in.
Some of the most notable, I
think, there was a kid who was
rushed to the emergency room
in a local hospital.
The doctor wasn't able to
perform the surgery.
And so the 15-, 16-year-old
kid was in a
life threatening situation.
And someone had the insight to
actually post to Google+.
And they were able to connect
with a doctor in a local city
and, actually using video, guide
him through the surgery,
save the child's life.
Certainly something different
was going on there.
In Calcutta, there is an
orphanage of hundreds and
hundreds of kids who don't
speak English.
And the way to get out
of an orphanage is
largely to have language.
And English is not an easy
language to pick up from an
orphanage, where they don't
really talk to you in English.
And so local university
professors volunteer their
time to actually teach English
in an auditorium much like
this to kids using Hangouts.
Probably the most memorable one
that I heard was one of
the father-in-laws of a Hangout
user was diagnosed
with Parkinson's.
And he knew that his time where
he was able to speak and
he was able to control his
hands was limited.
And so he pulled together all
of his grandkids into a
Hangout and taught them
how to tie a bow tie.
And that way, Hangouts has
really struck a nerve, an
emotional nerve and
a social nerve.
And what we've done as a team is
actually we've been blessed
with the community grabbing
hold and taking it so many
places that we've essentially
turned into a
highly reactive team.
And of the first things we
noticed was that as soon as
these conversations started to
be formed, people wanted the
ability to share them.
And the concept of sharing a
conversation isn't actually
possible without a product
like ours.
And so initially, it was
people recording those
conversations using their own
screen capture software,
putting them on disk, and
then uploading them.
But then we looked at each
other, and we said, well,
clearly, we're Google.
YouTube is potentially the
best video distribution
platform in the world.
Why don't we connect those
two things together?
And what we launched was
Hangouts on Air, which was
launched last winter essentially
as a way for
people to have a conversation
and
distribute it on the internet.
And everyday users were able
to do that, for the first
time, get a stage where they
can actually have a public
conversation.
But then the media grabbed it.
Because they wanted to find
conversations, elicit
conversation, and create
new conversations.
And I think that maybe the
mantra that we've started to
think about is Hangouts are a
great tool to connect you with
people that you know you want
to have a conversation with.
But also, our goal is to find
conversations you didn't think
you wanted to have.
And I think that's what's really
magical about what
we've seen so far.
STEVE GROVE: Discovering these
conversations that you
wouldn't have otherwise
had access to.
NIKHYL SINGHAL: Absolutely.
STEVE GROVE: Since we've started
and seen media using
Hangouts more and more, you
and I have had a chance to
meet with a couple
of broadcasters.
Tell our friends here a little
bit about what you've heard
from the media and other
partners who clearly have
video technology to create
conversations, but are really
grabbing onto Hangouts as a
way to engage audiences.
NIKHYL SINGHAL: So there's two
things that we continue to
hear, and they have a
lot to do with the
two things I mentioned.
One is people look at Hangouts
as a way to minimize the
satellite truck.
So it's a satellite truck
in your pocket
for the first time.
And so as a team, we've been
developing technology to
improve the quality of the
video, to think about vetting.
So how do I make sure that
the participants and the
conversation is curated?
How do I make sure that the
conversation's interactive?
And I think we're going to show
some things about that.
And so they look at it as a
replacement for being able to
pull together what they usually
do with studios, and
cameras, and very
expensive gear.
That's one side.
But then you have a situation
like what Sarah Hill did.
She's a very talented
broadcaster that is at a local
affiliate in Missouri.
And she's been using Google+
to find interesting
conversations.
So during the Montreal protests,
she found someone
hanging out live in Montreal who
is actually broadcasting
the protests from their--
I think it was their laptop
in that case.
Well, people livestream
all the time.
What made this unique was Sarah
jumped in the Hangout,
broadcast it on television, and
had a live conversation.
And so when you think about the
capability of being able
to find a conversation on a
breaking news event and be
able to push it out to the
rest of the world, that's
something that, I think, all
broadcasters are excited about
and they see the potential
there.
STEVE GROVE: Yeah, it's just a
huge possibility for citizen
reporting there, right?
NIKHYL SINGHAL: Absolutely.
STEVE GROVE: With mobile.
Well, I want to give folks here
in the audience and folks
online a chance to
ask questions.
So if you have one, please start
to line up at the mics.
We'll also check the Moderator
queue in a second.
But before I have the audience
questions, Chee, I'd like to
hear a bit more from you
about Hangout apps.
Because when Hangouts launched,
it was just this
multi-person video conversation
platform within
Google+, and then you launched
Hangout apps.
So tell us a little bit about
what does a developer need to
know to create a really
excellent Hangout app?
CHEE CHEW: As Nikhyl was saying,
very early on, people
started using Hangouts in ways
that we didn't imagine that
they would.
They really pushed the envelope
of what we had designed.
And so it was very evident very
early on that we would
need a way of enabling people
to be creative.
Because people think about
things that we
never thought of.
And the best way of doing that
is to enable this platform.
So the whole intent around that
platform was to allow
people to take video and their
apps, the apps that they
already have, and make them
better by adding video to it.
Make them better by making them
more collaborative and
more real-time.
And the whole platform effort we
had around that is just to
really facilitate new
experiences and new ideas and
to allow developers to really
enhance their applications.
The biggest takeaway I have
around the whole platform is
that we tried to make the
Hangout API platform really
simple and built upon the notion
that anything that you
can do in your app already on
the web, you can keep it and
just add Hangouts to it.
You don't have to redesign it.
You don't have to
re-architect it.
It is just adding.
You can take your app and iFrame
it into a Hangout, and
then add the multi-person and
the video capabilities onto
it, and extend it.
We did a session just now
just prior to this one.
And we have a code lab
at 4 o'clock today.
We can help people
go through that.
And then the other thing I'd
have you all developers
understand for us from this
point, especially here, but
ongoing, is our approach to the
platform is really to find
out what people are trying
to do and enable that.
So the feedback that you give
us on, hey, I'm trying to do
X, Y, or Z thing really helps
us plan and provide what
people need.
So that feedback loop here
today, but also just online,
ongoing is incredibly
valuable to us.
STEVE GROVE: So I pulled up
an unofficial site called
thehangoutapps.com that has a
bunch of these Hangout apps
listed there.
It's a good start for
inspiration for people
thinking about what types
of apps to develop.
What can you say about the
social dynamics of
multi-person video chat that a
developer can say, OK, well,
that's the kind of situation in
which a Hangout makes sense
around an application.
Do you have some
insight there?
CHEE CHEW: Well, whenever you
have an app where multiple
people are collaborating or
contributing to and sometimes
it's asynchronous, where one
person goes in, and another
person comes in later.
But once in a while,
they come in.
And they start using it, and
modifying it, and contributing
at the same time.
That sort of flow is a great
candidate for a Hangout.
And allowing people to work on
things asynchronously and also
make it come alive when it's in
a Hangout and then continue
afterwards.
I think from existing apps and
productivity apps, I think
that's really, really
important.
The dynamic for a fun
entertainment app inside a
Hangout, I think that there are
a couple of things that
you really have to
think about.
One is oftentimes people are
shooting the breeze, or
hanging around, and
doing whatever.
And then someone will
start using an app.
And then it will be fun, and it
will spread throughout the
rest of that Hangout app.
So a great Hangout app allows
for just 1 or 2
people to use it.
Even in a group of 10, 1 or 2
people to start to use it and
get some value out of it, and
then have other people see it
and virally get that.
It also allows people
to come and go.
Because in a Hangout,
someone can leave,
or someone can join.
So it allows a free flow of
people coming in and out.
If you think about the dynamics
of that-- which
happens in real life as well.
Two people start playing cards,
someone joins, and then
someone else comes in later.
Think about those dynamics.
I think facilitating what really
happens in real life.
That's what you want to think
about when you build apps.
STEVE GROVE: Yeah, I think the
online poker app is one of
those really natural use cases
for people coming together.
CHEE CHEW: Absolutely.
NIKHYL SINGHAL: It's probably
worth pointing out that
there's two styles of apps
that we've been seeing.
I think one are the YouTube,
poker, kind of mainstream
activities that if you take a
group of people and you're
essentially in a room, what
could you give them to keep
them busy, to keep
them occupied.
The most successful app that
actually we have is our Google
Effects app.
And we're seeing a lot of
developers build almost tools
or enhancements to the
video conversation.
And these, if you look at a
Hangout, are the ones that
show up on the left side.
They're not designed to be a
service or an activity in and
of themselves.
They're actually designed to
say, well, if you're in a
conversation, what could we do
with the audio, the video, or
the management of the
conversation that would really
make the conversation
more effective?
And I think that both are going
to be interesting areas
of exploration as we start to
see developers roll those out.
CHEE CHEW: Those extensions that
extend and enhance the
existing conversation, I think,
are ones that you don't
need to get the consensus
of other people.
Any one person can add value.
And everyone sees what's
happening and is like, oh, how
do I do that?
Like the Lower Third app or
the Comment Tracker app.
There are a bunch of things like
that which really do well
in that sort of forum.
STEVE GROVE: One of my favorite
Hangout Effects apps
was Conan Hair, which we
launched for a Hangout we did
with Conan O'Brien in which you
can essentially place a
giant frock of orange hair on
top of your head, as you're
hanging out and play
like you're a late
night talk show host.
CHEE CHEW: Yeah, of course,
Conan threatened to sue us for
that one, so you gotta be
careful with those.
STEVE GROVE: Yeah, indeed.
You're just kidding,
of course.
CHEE CHEW: Yeah.
STEVE GROVE: Let's take
some questions.
What questions do we have in
the audience for Chee and
Nikhyl on Hangouts?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Breon Nagy with Code
42 software.
Using the webcam's pretty easy,
using your camera on
your phone's pretty easy.
But what about when you want to
broadcast a group of people?
What kind of camera and
interface to a computer would
you recommend?
How do you get the image from
a HDMI camcorder into the
computer to broadcast?
CHEE CHEW: Well, the interfaces
that we use to
connect to the camera are the
standard operating system
interfaces, like WTIA
on Windows.
So we will take in the input
from the operating system.
Sometimes people want to pipe
in other video sources that
aren't directly cameras.
And there are softcam emulators
that present
themselves as cameras.
But we'll just have a
standard interface.
There are some high-end tools,
like Blackmagic Intensity Pro,
which we use very
successfully.
I think there are a bunch
of things like that that
you can look at.
At the end of the day, at this
point, the resolution of it is
capped, so we don't
go to HD yet.
It's certainly something that
we're definitely looking into,
but I think that those are the
tools that I would look at.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
STEVE GROVE: Over here.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Ryan Nichols with Podio.
I'm interested to hear you guys
talk a little bit about
enterprise applications of
Hangouts, both your vision for
Hangouts in the enterprise, as
well as I'm just curious how
you're using it internally.
I'm curious whether your own
salespeople are hanging out
with customers and that
sort of thing.
NIKHYL SINGHAL: So I joined
Google about 18 months ago.
And probably my first day, I
was struck by the fact that
almost every conference room
has video conferencing
equipment, and almost all
meetings are video meetings.
CHEE CHEW: When you joined,
you tried to have a phone
conversation with me.
NIKHYL SINGHAL: I was like,
can I give you a call?
CHEE CHEW: And I was like,
I don't have a phone.
STEVE GROVE: I only hang out.
NIKHYL SINGHAL: They just don't
give phones to employees.
And so I did five phone calls a
day before I joined Google.
I've done four since I've
been at Google.
We just use our video
conferencing systems
internally, which is one of
the ways we've gotten to
understand the use cases
that Chee referred to.
So today, just to give you a
sense of how Google uses
Hangouts, we do over 10,000
Hangouts every day at Google
to connect our company.
CHEE CHEW: We run our business
on Hangouts.
NIKHYL SINGHAL: And so that's
really changed--
STEVE GROVE: 10,000 a day.
NIKHYL SINGHAL: 10,000 a day.
Actually, it's slightly more.
Like I said, that has really
changed the way that people
have interactions.
It's also made it possible for
the Hangout team to be largely
in Kirkland and in Stockholm.
And so it's not surprising that
there's a great, great
pent-up demand on the
enterprise side.
And what we've done is we've
been slowly releasing our
services to the enterprise
crowd.
There's a number of apps that
actually exist within Hangouts
that are almost what I would
call productivity apps.
Our Google Docs Integrations
First Class.
YouTube has been used
for webinars.
CHEE CHEW: Screen Sharer.
NIKHYL SINGHAL: Screen Sharer
is a very popular case.
So I think that we don't have
anything to announce today.
But I think that it's clear to
say that part of the reason
why we invest so heavily
internally in technologies
like Hangouts is to understand
the opportunity for
enterprises.
And we've been very encouraged
by the initial results.
CHEE CHEW: I think that we, for
Google, have found that it
actually makes our engineering
and our
business more efficient.
If you do an interview over a
phone, you're missing a lot of
the nuance of the
conversation.
You're missing reading
the body language.
You don't have as high quality
a read on the person you're
talking to.
So we firmly believe, especially
as distributed as
Google is, if you use things
like video technology and it's
high quality, you will make your
business more efficient.
So we think of it as actually
a competitive advantage.
NIKHYL SINGHAL: And there's
actually an insight that we
had early in the launch
of Google+.
We always think that there's
the enterprise use case.
And the enterprise use case is
when you're serious, and you
have directed conversations,
and their private and
access-controlled.
Then there's this, social
lightweight, fun, maybe you
meet someone new
type of thing.
Well, we started to see people
like Michael Dell actually use
Hangouts as a way to understand
how people think
about Dell products.
Customer support apps, where
people would use video calling
as a way to actually engage
in the public.
So the notion of an unstructured
conversation in
the enterprise is actually
a really, really
ripe area to innovate.
And I think you'll see the
blending of social and
enterprise really delivering
on a new style of
communication that I think we're
just starting to see
even internally.
STEVE GROVE: There's an
authenticity you get in that
conversation face to face about
a product that you just
don't get in comments and
things like that.
NIKHYL SINGHAL: That's right.
STEVE GROVE: The topic of a
question out of Moderator
right now is really
a good one.
It comes from [? Zyzigu. ?]
And it is the following.
Talk, Google+ Messenger,
Hangouts, and Voice all have
overlapping features while
remaining separate.
Can we expect better
consolidation between these
down the road?
Nikhyl.
NIKHYL SINGHAL: Yes, I think
we've done an incredibly poor
job of servicing
our users here.
We have all the code to make
a seamless communication
experience for end users,
but they live in lots
of different products.
We're going to fix that.
We are highly, highly committed
to providing a
single, clean, beautiful user
experience for having
real-time communication.
It will happen.
We don't have anything to
announce, but it is an
investment that we care
deeply about.
CHEE CHEW: Across all these
different surfaces, as well.
NIKHYL SINGHAL: Across
all surfaces.
CHEE CHEW: Across all devices.
NIKHYL SINGHAL: That's right.
STEVE GROVE: Clearly, both of
your titles are director of
product engineering for
real-time communications, not
just Hangouts.
NIKHYL SINGHAL: That's right.
STEVE GROVE: Let's
go over here.
Next question.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
My name is Justin Davenport.
I'm with Virginia Tech.
What I'm curious of is on this
same enterprise topic, has
there been any discussion about
integrating H.323 or SIP
endpoints into Google+?
And have you looked
at any teaching or
education use cases?
CHEE CHEW: Can I ask you, what
is it that you want out of
both SIP and H.323?
AUDIENCE: Well, we have lots
of faculty that are looking
for more advanced teaching
methods.
And they see the commercial
technology of Google+.
And they expect something like
that in the classroom or
delivered online, something
beyond just a TV and a H.323
link between two classrooms.
CHEE CHEW: So I'm still not
quite clear on what is it that
you want specifically from
the 323 and also SIP?
AUDIENCE: I'm sorry.
It's two separate issues.
I guess the first question
is let's say if we had 20
students sitting at home, a
faculty in their office, do
you see a use case for that
for Google+ in the future?
CHEE CHEW: This is actually a
very common thing that we will
do, where someone will ask
for a specific piece of
functionality, like, I
want SIP integration.
And what we really want to do
is we want to dig in a layer
deeper and say, hey, what is
the scenario that you want?
And what I hear from you is,
we want to have the ability
for teachers to have a
conversation, a class lecture,
and for people at home, students
to not necessarily
join in the Hangout, but also to
be able to consume it in a
really cheap, easy, quick way.
And we definitely want to
solve that scenario.
Hangouts on Air is sort
of one format of that.
Although currently, Hangouts
on Air require you to
broadcast to the entire world.
But the notion of wanting to
filter that down to a circle
and broadcast that to a subset
is definitely something that
we've heard the request for.
And we definitely recognize
there is a need there.
NIKHYL SINGHAL: So in my
opinion, I think there's
certain use cases for Hangouts,
where Hangouts is
always just a better answer.
I think office hours are
somewhat broken today.
And what I mean by that is
when I was in college--
I know it was a while ago
but-- usually what would
happen is a professor would
sit in their room or the
teaching assistant,
and they'd wait.
And then you would essentially
have a student walk in.
And the student would walk in
maybe 20 minutes in, and they
would ask a question about
problem set number two.
He'd answer the question, and
then the student would leave.
Another guy would come in and
ask the same question, and
they would repeat the
same question.
And what would happen is then
there was a handful of people
that actually had gone to office
hours, who seemed to
have the insight, and the
people that didn't.
So in my opinion, every office
hour in the world for every
institution should be always
run with a Hangout in mind.
Because then you
can broadcast.
People can jump in, they can
actually ask the questions.
You could record, you
can play it back.
You can clip the section that is
actually interesting, share
it to the world.
This we are committed
to doing.
The product today actually
does a fairly good job.
We're starting to see
people come in.
There has been some concerns
around privacy.
We haven't heard the technical
concern that you mentioned.
But I suspect there is probably
issues around
[INAUDIBLE].
CHEE CHEW: But the way that
we're doing this, you could
connect to it via a Flash
Player, or a video tag, or
something really simple
like that.
NIKHYL SINGHAL: So it's an
area that we're really
interested in investing in.
Medicine and education
are two of the
verticals that we're really--
I would say-- hyper-investing
in.
STEVE GROVE: There's just a lot
of efficiencies when you
start taking a Hangout from just
being the 10 people there
and then making it a
broadcast Hangout.
NIKHYL SINGHAL: That's right.
STEVE GROVE: Let's
go over here.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Mike Corbett.
Android Headlines.
I was wondering if it would be
possible in the future--
and I know you can't
talk about some
future things, but--
if Hangouts on Air was planned
for mobile in the future.
CHEE CHEW: You mean
plan to join?
Broadcast?
I guess both.
STEVE GROVE: This is also the
number two question on the
Moderator right now.
NIKHYL SINGHAL: Maybe I'll
club them all together.
I would say essentially
everything that we do on the
desktop, the plan and the
intention, is for us to have
them available on
all surfaces.
So as far as I know, we don't
have a single feature that is
desktop specific.
It turns out from a sequencing
point of view, as you point
out, both our platform for apps,
as well as our Hangout
on Air product line and our
feature set are the two that
we don't currently
have supported.
I think we took a big step today
actually by launching
our tablet support, which had
Hangouts fully integrated,
which is one of the most
commonly asked questions, and
the mobile phone support.
And for those of you that
haven't done a video call on a
tablet, it's very different
than you may think.
Think about where you hold your
phone, where you hold
your tablet, and where
you hold your
desktop in your house.
So when you hold a tablet, and
you have a video conversation,
and it's with your friends and
family, particularly those
that you don't see very often,
you hold it on the left, and
you hold it on the right.
It's almost like you're hugging
the person, and you're
in this conversation.
That degree of intimacy changes
the style of the
conversation.
So we're really excited about
the fact that we're pushing
now on all of our different
surfaces.
But it is a clear investment
that we will have those
capabilities.
But we don't have it in a
time frame that we can
announce right now.
CHEE CHEW: Anytime when you see
something that's not on
one of those platforms, the
answer why it's not there is
almost certainly either a
technical limitation, where we
can't, but we want to, or our
engineers just aren't typing
fast enough.
And we need to get them
to type faster.
NIKHYL SINGHAL: More coffee.
CHEE CHEW: More coffee.
STEVE GROVE: A lot of the
questions on the Moderator are
asking about television.
And since you mentioned tablet,
it might be a good
time to address this one.
AUDIENCE: That was actually my
second question was about the
Q. Would the Q be possible if
you have Hangouts on it?
NIKHYL SINGHAL: You
can [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: It is running ICS.
CHEE CHEW: I think that's
something we'll have to take a
look at with the
Google TV guys.
NIKHYL SINGHAL: So the iOS
application supports air time
in a native way.
And so the idea of--
I think it's embedded in your
question, which is can I take
a Hangout and make it work
on a television.
It's a very classic question.
It's a great question.
With iOS, we're able to
start seeing that.
Clearly, we're committed
to doing that on the
Googlestack as well.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
STEVE GROVE: You can imagine
putting your television or
your tablet at one of the dinner
chairs at dinnertime
and actually enjoying a meal
with somebody who's
actually not there.
Let's go over here.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I just want to follow up on the
enterprise question before.
So in large corporations, you
often have this meetings where
you're broadcasting
to everybody.
And it's a really expensive way
to communicate to folks.
Hangouts offer another
solution for us.
And I'm just wondering is there
a way to have folks join
a Hangout without having to
have the participation?
So if you can imagine
40,000 people
needing to join a Hangout.
We don't really want to have
40,000 people join a Hangout
per se, but we'd love to be
able to broadcast and
communicate with
them that way.
CHEE CHEW: So if I could reframe
your question, I think
what you're asking for is if you
want people to be able to
join, but not actually
participate, but consume it,
you're actually asking for
Hangouts on Air, but
restricted to your company.
Is that fair?
AUDIENCE: Or maybe in some
ways participate.
Maybe voting or something
like that.
Just some ideas to help
out the use cases.
CHEE CHEW: So the notion
of these use cases,
I think, are great.
It is a very common thing
that we've had a
lot of requests for.
What Steve has up here
is an app that
we're actually building.
It is using the platform.
And what this does
is it combines
Hangouts with Moderator.
So someone can view a Hangout.
And then at same time, over
there on the left side, they
can ask a question.
And then other people can
vote on that question.
Oh, yeah, I want to
ask that question.
And then the people inside the
Hangout, whoever's presenting
on it, will see those questions,
and they'll see
them bubble up.
And they can respond to it.
And this is a platform aspect
that we want to bring forth to
allow scenarios that we were
just talking about, as well as
many others scenarios that the
media has been asking for.
AUDIENCE: So at Google, you say,
you have 10,000 of these
a day, I guess, right?
Do you see the need for
broadcast ideas?
CHEE CHEW: We definitely have
the one-to-many meetings.
Right now, Hangouts
are limited to 10.
But we often have meetings where
there are a few people
speaking, but there may be a
large team of 100 who want to
attend that meeting
and watch it.
Yeah, there's no question
that we have that.
NIKHYL SINGHAL: The use cases
typically either it's just a
pure streaming use case, which
is a handful of people want to
be able to speak, and
they want to be able
to reach the masses.
We get a lot of questions
around record.
So the ability to have a
conversation, and have it
recorded, and then be able to
play it back for future use.
And then the third is the key
point that Chee raised which
was when the audience is able
to be in that view mode, how
can you have that subtle
interaction?
Being inside the video
conversation is heavyweight.
And usually you have to
have a speaking role.
Being able to say, I think
that's a great question or
being able to submit your own
question without coming up to
the mic in this example, being
able to do that on what we
call Google Moderator, if you
were to club this together,
this is the number one ask
from broadcasters today.
We have a product that's
broadcasting, but it's how can
I engage the audience that's
watching in addition to engage
the audience that is
participating?
STEVE GROVE: We did a Hangout
with President Obama in early
February in which questions were
submitted on Moderator.
But we did that over on YouTube
and had to port those
back over into Google+ to not
only have the five people in
the Hangout asking questions
of the President, but
answering some of those
top-voted questions as well.
So with this application, I
think it's going to get a lot
more seamless.
Thanks for the question.
It was a really good one.
One of the top-voted questions
here that is somewhat related
is, why only 10?
Why only 10 people
in a Hangout?
CHEE CHEW: Because it's more
than 5 and less than 15.
STEVE GROVE: That's
a great answer.
NIKHYL SINGHAL: Next.
CHEE CHEW: I don't know if
you've ever been at a dinner
conversation where you had
15 people at the table.
When you have 15 people at a
table, you don't have one
conversation unless it's a
business meeting where there's
order to it and all that
sort of stuff.
If this is a social dinner table
of that size, it shards
into multiple conversations.
Our observation, just using the
product, is that somewhere
above 10, the conversation
starts getting cumbersome.
Too many people interrupt each
other, or people feel
frustrated because they want a
turn to talk, and all that
sort of stuff.
And when we were using it
ourselves at 15, it wasn't a
great conversation.
So it's a social
sort of thing.
STEVE GROVE: It's not
a technical limit.
It's simply--
CHEE CHEW: Well, we had a bug
that accidentally came out a
few months ago where we pushed
the server to where the cap
was removed.
And we had a 40% Hangout
out in the public.
And people got to experience
that the technology could hold
up to a pretty large number.
But the conversation just
couldn't handle--
STEVE GROVE: A shouting match.
CHEE CHEW: Everyone would try
to speak, and it was like
stepping on each other's toes.
It wasn't a healthy
conversation.
Now at the same time, if you
have a room of 10-- and let's
say our limit was 20--
and your buddy wants to come in,
you're not really going to
tell him, no.
So you're going to allow
it to go to 11.
And then another friend
comes and says, oh,
hey, let me in there.
And so you're going to
allow it to go to 12.
And then another person comes in
who wants to get in there,
and you're going to allow
it to go to 15 and 20.
You're not going to say, no to
your friends, say, oh, hey, we
have 10 right now, and that's
a little bit too many, so
please don't come in.
So essentially, we'll
help you by--
STEVE GROVE: Good fences
make good neighbors.
NIKHYL SINGHAL: I think that
part of the reason why we did
Hangouts on Air was also to
recognize that when you're in
that mode, where you are hosted,
is to allow people to
actually participate in
the conversation.
STEVE GROVE: You look at
broadcasters using Hangouts,
and it's rare that a broadcaster
like CNN or ABC
will actually have 10 people.
Usually it's 3 to 6.
Because even beyond that, if
you're trying to broadcast a
conversation that flows with
some kind of regularity, it,
in some ways, mirrors the
talking head format of cable
television.
When you're watching Fox or
MSNBC, there's never much more
than three or four blocks
on the screen.
There's too much to handle for
an audience once you get past
that limit.
Let's go over here.
AUDIENCE: Hi, I'm Colin Jones.
I'm interested in where
you're going with HD.
We're starting to see 4K cameras
drop into the prosumer
price range.
And particularly for medical
applications, that type of
resolution's pretty exciting.
And even just HD's much--
well, more is better,
right, in this case?
So I'm interested in both your
short- and long-term plans for
higher resolutions.
CHEE CHEW: Well, we're always
looking at how we can improve
the media quality.
That's incredibly important.
Not only, I think, more
pixels on the screen,
but also frame rate.
Getting up to the 30 frames per
second, it was important
for the responsiveness and
the overall experience.
It's definitely something
we're looking into.
There are lots of challenges
around doing that.
As you push up the frame rate
and the resolution, you
challenge the CPU.
You might not be able to hit
certain classes of machines
and that sort of thing.
So it takes a lot of
tuning on our part.
We don't have anything to
announce right now, but
there's no question that
we're going to be
moving in that direction.
One of the things we do also
recognize is that when you
want to see high resolution
x-rays or something like that,
where you're then casting
another screen or a window, we
actually adjust the
resolution.
So we'll go HD and above
resolution on a screen cast,
and we'll drop the frame rate
down to five per second in
order for you to get that really
nice, crisp HD screen.
So we don't have a specific
time line
or anything to announce.
But the philosophy I'd have
you understand is we're
definitely pushing in
that direction.
We're going to push the envelope
as hard as we can on
the overall quality of the
audio and the video.
But respecting the broad array
of hardware devices that we
have to support.
STEVE GROVE: Here's an
interesting question from Tim.
We've been talking a lot about
ambient conversations, but
what about scheduled
conversations?
Tim asks, what about Hangouts
integration with Google
Calendar so that you can
directly schedule a Hangout
and then invite users?
Is that something that
we're thinking about?
NIKHYL SINGHAL: Yeah, we're
definitely moving in the
direction of moving the Google
product stack and integrating
it more thoroughly
with Hangouts.
So I think it's safe to say
that you'll see Hangouts
appear in your favorite Google
products more readily.
Having said that, one of the
announcements we are making
today is the Google+
Events product.
And so for the first time,
we've made it relatively
simple for users that, say,
have a family circle to be
able to schedule that using
Google+ Events.
It's literally a click.
Create an event.
It's the special type called
a Hangout Event.
There'll be a link.
It'll show up in
your calendar.
You'll be able to join.
You'll get notified on mobile.
It's a great way of actually
having that scheduled
conversation.
And it leverages the group's,
then, relationships you've
already created on Google+.
CHEE CHEW: And as Nikhyl
said, that does
show up on your calendar.
And so you get all the calendar
functionality there.
And one of the subtle points
that I know was brought out
earlier is that that creates a
Hangout location URL that's
static, persistent.
So at the time that you create
that event, you now have a
Hangout URL that you can
join at any point.
You don't have to go through
the create at a time and
invite everyone thing that
you do with the ambient
conversations.
NIKHYL SINGHAL: And I think
inherent in that question is
there has been a deep investment
that you're going
to start seeing come out over
the summer around making that
directed use case, which is a
very common use case, is I
want to call grandma, I want
to call my brother.
Making that simpler, and easier,
reducing the friction,
making that available on all
services, this has been a big
investment the team has made.
We feel like we've done really
interesting work around the
social and the ambient
use case.
We really want to get that
directed right, and this is
the first step in doing that.
CHEE CHEW: One of the tricks
that some of the folks on our
team have figured out and used
for the events is if you have
a recurring Hangout once a
week, you could create an
event that's actually scheduled
out, say, next year.
And that creates a Hangout link
that you can use every
week, all the time, week
after week after
week, so the same location.
So a common request that we've
had is, I'd like to have a
static URL, so I can just
know where to go.
I know where to go, and I just
have it posted somewhere.
And I can bookmark it.
And so with Events, you can
effectively do that.
STEVE GROVE: So your wife and
your son can have their
homework Hangout always open,
check in, see that he's doing
his homework.
A few more minutes left.
Let's try to get as many
questions as we can.
Next.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
My name is Christopher.
My question has to do with more
of a general in terms of
Hangout environment
for individual.
And the best way I can explain
is through an experience that
I had using Hangouts, whereby
my wife and I--
I was in Boston at the time.
She was in Seattle.
It was our anniversary.
And we thought, oh,
we can hang out
to have dinner together.
But then I have this really
dangly brick wall behind me,
and she has this really crappy
tree with nothing
on the back of it.
I was like, oh, I really wish I
could just take a two-minute
clip of where we had dinner once
and have it basically go
and compress and overlap
upon that video.
And so that you have that
general environment of that we
are having dinner in a place
that we can see not only
ourselves, but in the
background, which is less of a
distraction, but more of a
visually appealing experience.
And secondly, it would be more
of two, as well as friends and
I, we love drinking at a bar.
But we're never together.
But it would be nice to go
in and then have in a bar
environment, where we can
just sit there and
have a drink together.
And it actually feel like in a
bar environment in some sense.
And I understand that
visualizations can be very complex.
But you're Google, so it
shouldn't be impossible.
NIKHYL SINGHAL: If you asked if
you were jumping out of an
airplane at the same time,
then maybe we would get
excited about that.
CHEE CHEW: Putting that in
the blimp would be all
you'd need to do.
It's a good request.
AUDIENCE: I guess that's a
general request more than a
question of do you have
anything to do with
[INAUDIBLE].
CHEE CHEW: We're definitely
looking at what interesting
things can you do with
a video stream.
Effects was one step along the
way, and we're continuing that
foot forward.
We don't have any specific,
and I will definitely take
that as feedback of a request
that we [INAUDIBLE].
NIKHYL SINGHAL: It's
a great use case.
STEVE GROVE: It brings up this
point of context, right?
The context within which you're
having a conversation
makes all the difference.
So whether you're starting a
Hangout based off an article
you've discovered, or in the
context of a bar you've been
at, or wherever, it's setting
that right tone to have the
right kind of conversation.
AUDIENCE: Like in the video that
you showed, this girl had
a bunch of books in
the background.
I don't have any use for
that personally.
But [INAUDIBLE].
I totally am not focused on
the background itself, but
just more of the personal
[INAUDIBLE].
We tend to think that
STEVE GROVE: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
My name is Brent.
One of the favorite Hangouts
I've ever done was at the top
of a hiking trail, where I
happened to catch a 3G signal,
enough to be able to do a
Hangout out to my parents and
just show them this amazing
view that I saw.
I also know several people who
are in the sign language
interpreting field.
And they see this as being a
good benefit for the deaf and
harder of hearing community.
The problem I see is, especially
in low bandwidth
situations, it seems like
Google+ prioritizes audio over
video and tries to keep the
audio connection going as much
as possible.
Are there any plans of making it
so that you can potentially
tell the Hangout to prioritize
the video signal over audio?
Or maybe that audio isn't needed
at all and put all the
bandwidth towards the video?
CHEE CHEW: So that's
very interesting.
So I'm hard of hearing
as well.
And so I do sign language,
so I really care a
lot about that scenario.
For the majority of use cases,
it is true that we think that
audio is extremely important.
If the audio is laggy, or it is
choppy, or it turns into a
robot-y voice, it's hard
to have a conversation.
If you start dropping video
frames, you can still have a
conversation if the
audio is clean.
But I think that what you're
describing is actually a
really important case as well.
There are a few things that
we're doing with that.
We're experimenting with
the low bandwidth mode.
And we drop the resolution, but
keep the frames higher.
We do that in the download, and
we're looking at playing
around with the upload.
And we're playing around with
automatic detection for that.
The other thing is if you just
simply mute your microphone,
then that will give us a signal
that we're going to
prioritize that.
And if everyone else does that,
we will adjust that.
Because when we don't detect
audio, we will give that
bandwidth to the video.
There are a few things that
you can do, but we're also
working to make that better.
AUDIENCE: Is that done today?
If you mute the audio, does it
prioritize video completely?
CHEE CHEW: It adjusts.
So when you aren't sending any
audio, then we don't consume
the bandwidth for that.
AUDIENCE: Great, thank you.
STEVE GROVE: Let's take
one more question.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
My name's Andrew.
I helped organize a 48-hour
code jam among a bunch of
college students.
But we purposely made it so we
weren't at a same place.
We were at a bunch of
different places.
And we were trying to figure
out something to use.
So we ended up trying
to use Hangouts.
But Hangouts on Air, I believe,
was invite only, so
we couldn't get access
to that.
So we set up this complicated
rebroadcasting thing to try to
get it to broadcast
to audience.
And in the end, it didn't work
because our listeners for each
Hangout would time-out after--
I think it was-- an
hour and a half.
And there was also this other
problem of we could only share
one screen at a time, and we
couldn't get multiple people
to share screens.
Because once someone
shares a screen, it
overrides the main screen.
And the last thing I just wanted
to mention is it was
really hard to get recording
to work because we had this
complicated thing.
I didn't really have
a question.
It was just a bunch of sharing
my experience with you.
NIKHYL SINGHAL: So let me
maybe tease that apart a
little bit.
So Hangouts on Air launched a
few months ago generally, and
it's now at 100% across
the world.
So for most countries in the
world, you actually can have
Hangouts on Air.
We know we had so much demand.
We really wanted to make sure
that when people are
broadcasting themselves,
it's important for the
quality to be good.
So we feel like we're
there now.
CHEE CHEW: And that includes
recording.
NIKHYL SINGHAL: And that
includes recording.
So I think if you were to try
it again, you'd be able to
take advantage of that.
When it comes to being able to
what takes over the main
image, we actually allow the
user to click on what we call
the film strip, which
is the set of images
underneath the Hangout.
And any time you click on one
of those images, it actually
changes the main screen image.
And it actually would affect
what's being broadcast.
So this is a way for President
Obama to be in a Hangout, and
then you can actually click over
to someone who's talking
if you want to override
the default.
CHEE CHEW: So more people can
screencast at a time.
And we do that every day.
Lots of people will
simultaneously screencast.
AUDIENCE: When we did it, when
we clicked Share Screen, it
would override the
other person's.
And then it would kick
them back to their
webcam when we did it.
CHEE CHEW: You should
give it a try again.
It shouldn't do that anymore.
AUDIENCE: OK.
And then I guess the only other
comment I have is you
said that when you do screen
sharing, it prioritizes the
quality, but reduces
the frame rate.
CHEE CHEW: It prioritizes
resolution over frame rate in
a screencast.
AUDIENCE: We were also trying
to develop games.
We were trying to show off this
crazy thing, and it was
running at 2 FPS.
CHEE CHEW: One of the things
that we should actually take a
look at is giving API support
for developers to say, hey, I
want to prioritize or pump up
frames over resolution.
I think we can take
that as good
feedback for our platform.
STEVE GROVE: We're almost
out of time.
I want to give each of you 30
seconds to tell us what you're
most excited about for the
future of Hangouts on Google+.
Let's start with you, Nikhyl.
NIKHYL SINGHAL: Oh.
CHEE CHEW: Oh.
STEVE GROVE: You can flip
a coin if you want.
NIKHYL SINGHAL: So as I started
this session, I think
we're in the really early,
early parts of social and
real-time communication.
The thing I'm most excited
about is the pursuit of
enabling users to have
conversations they didn't know
they could be having.
I think that's a very
Google-like mission.
Google's incredibly good at
finding content that's
interesting.
I think that Hangouts make it
possible to find people that
are interesting.
And I'm looking forward to
coming back next year and
seeing how we're doing there.
STEVE GROVE: Very cool.
Chee?
CHEE CHEW: I think that video
conferencing is still in the
really early stages.
And not everyone is comfortable
automatically
doing that.
People are like, oh, but I'm not
wearing anything nice, or
I don't have my makeup on.
You have all these excuses
right now.
And I fully believe that in the
coming years, it will just
come natural.
People won't think about it.
In the past, people really
noticed when you had a cell
phone or really noticed when you
were walking and talking
to yourself.
You looked weird or whatever.
And today, everyone
has a cell phone.
And video will become
commonplace.
Multiwave video, pulling people
in, that fluidity will
become commonplace.
People aren't there yet.
They're not used to it yet.
But there's no question it's
going to get there.
And I think it's going to open
up a lot of possibilities.
STEVE GROVE: Very cool.
Well, thank you both.
And thank you to everyone
here for joining us.
We appreciate it.
I want to mention before you
go that there's a Hangouts
Code Lab, I believe,
in room four.
Room two.
But this is room two.
AUDIENCE: The lab.
STEVE GROVE: Oh, in Code Lab 2
starting at 4 o'clock, which
is 15 minutes from now.
So lots of folks are
going to be there.
They're going to build
a Hangout app
from the ground up.
You'll get a real good sense
for how this works.
Thanks again for coming.
Thanks everyone online
for joining us.
As you leave, we're going to
play a quick highlight reel
from the Hangout we did
with President Obama.
It's not often you get the
President to use your
technology.
We had a lot of fun with it.
We learned a lot about how to
get citizens access to figures
of power in this Hangout.
So as you head on out,
we'll play a little
highlight reel of that.
Thanks again for coming,
everybody.